in five four three two one let's check
if the [ __ ] is on in the first place
yeah on on ready to go
welcome everybody to an episode of the
genius brain podcast I've been trying to
get this [ __ ] in the [ __ ] for
the longest time but we're here
aw travel a lot bro listen Roman Romans
what they call this and when in Rome
Rome travels I try to get out I try that
I'm not I'm not a house I'm not a house
guy not house guy but I'm as I'm getting
older I'm becoming a house guy you what
why do you like travelling so much my
parents in the military so I been
traveling since jump
born in Germany mood Massachusetts
Panama Florida North Carolina didn't
when they landed for college moved out
here I could literally pick up and leave
right now so I believe in the middle
podcast man when I had a [ __ ] mic and
a manual right here man
like we were supposed to there's
something I wanted to ask you just
because we were supposed to get into the
podcast but and they were gonna talk
about it but we didn't get into it Oh
like the missing member of dorm tame it
okay like just what are the [ __ ] did he
go listen the best way I can put it is
like [ __ ] happens like honestly and in
2016 it just got to a point we're like
you know what we gotta part ways as
amicable as possible and that that's
that's pretty much like this with how it
goes of course it's deeper than that but
it's like it's is it it is what it is at
this point and people still ask me like
it's been three years guys like yeah we
put out a statement like hey no longer
part of the group but it's okay nobody
I'm not nobody has any beef and then
like that's just one of those things
were like in a group dynasty goes there
dynamics there's people one person may
feel this way if they don't communicate
and you know as humans communication is
our worst part we don't know how to
communicate so but then it gets to a
point where he's like alright maybe
something's a little off so let's uh
let's just call it how it is and you
know if that's what if we we we've moved
on and like it's just five of us now so
what six now five of us it's still a lot
of people know you over him a lot of
a lot of it went from a lot of people to
like kind of a lot of people some same
[ __ ] but yeah me when he was in the
group he did a lot of uh he did a lot of
music
yeah yeah right yeah yeah me and him
because we both went to school for audio
production yeah what so mix and master
and all that so do you do all the all
the when you guys were originally doing
all like the you guys original music is
[ __ ] we at least we flipped in flop
everybody I do everything now for my me
and cams group tropical storm which is
one of the few if you haven't heard the
tropical storm it's a group of two guys
two rappers and our number one hit is a
song called dick touch the water
phenomenal song phenomenal song but yeah
so I do all the tracks for that Mike you
know Mike's men in the production and
stuff now for a little while so he's
been making beats for our new show room
noise and stuff like that we've all been
a musically inclined group which is kind
of weird it's very interesting that only
two of us went to school for actual
music but everybody has like an ear for
music and that's just [ __ ] hard
though man like oh yes tough doing
comedy music is [ __ ] difficult and I
don't think people realize that [ __ ]
because there's a couple of people right
now that are trying to do comedy albums
and I heard it and that [ __ ] is terrible
rush it like I'm gonna let you know it's
not good yeah the problem is especially
like in the space because I feel like
there's a lot of people that I like like
I [ __ ] with you right yeah yeah
and me being an opinionated comic I want
to talk about how trash their [ __ ] is
yeah but at the same time I it's it's I
think it's a bad look for me to go out
of my way to trash somebody's work yeah
because it's like unless they you can't
let's just like waking up in the morning
calling them hey I listen to your album
you say it just wasn't good my [ __ ] man
I just woke up like yeah they have at
least ask you like you don't say like
hey what you think and then you give
even then you have to kind of like you
got a presented to him in like like it's
like presenting somebody like a a bowl
of [ __ ] with a knife with a nice garnish
around it like here and I don't know -
it really depends on how much I like the
person like if I really like the Priya
now and then I'll like tiptoe around
yeah certain word maybe you
to work on yeah but if I don't if I if
we're just like barely there that I'm
like miss [ __ ] was [ __ ] terrible man
what the [ __ ] were you thinking
no like people I thought a lot of people
ask they like so you guys like cuz our
showroom noise we take a don't even know
how the [ __ ] you do that that's just so
hard we take a topic like cartoons throw
a bunch of old cartoons in there pick a
cartoon out pick a vibe out the box
whether it's reggae whether it's I don't
know anything pop with it whatever it is
pick a vibe and then we create had to
create the song on the spot there that
one track that you guys did the kind of
had like a Outkast vibe oh yeah that was
a [ __ ] Claud we had old man names you
had [ __ ] Jase no dawg I haven't heard
of that dude in a [ __ ] minute he came
in here killed it was great it was the
way we get and it's funny because each
time we pick something out the bowl it's
never something that we want without
[ __ ] yeah we gotta figure this and for
this and how editing usually works is I
always just edited to make it look like
we but now we stick with the same thing
we're like we gotta cheap we got to keep
the integrity of the show I don't like
that word but keep the integrity of the
show and so we end up just sticking with
it and usually the ones we don't want
are the best songs that we end up doing
like when we picked Lando from Star Wars
when when what's good was on with us we
like I don't know anything about and we
went research and we end up coming with
a fire song for Lando les is like if you
guys don't know who wes is was good he
actually he went to school with a buddy
of mine that was for this other company
called JK films and they all went to
Full Sail yeah oh just like our school
Wes [ __ ] Matt talented after the B's
and I always thought that you know when
that whole vine [ __ ] was poppin earlier
Wes never got as much respect as the
other people did but his content was
better here's the thing Wes was helping
everybody with the [ __ ] that's the crazy
part
oh really people know I think Wes was
behind the scenes like Shawn cuz he you
know he come from a director film that
he's a film very light so I think he's
behind a saying he knows all these
people and then he got to upon who's
like wait I'm helping everybody to do my
own [ __ ] and that's when he started
doing it but I know Wes a super talent
like yeah like very like I saw his
videos and he's open he's on that
director side so when
when he went on the vine thing I think
his his vines and his Instagram videos
were always a level above everybody
else's but they weren't dumb enough to
pop off that's what I always said about
a [ __ ] that's the [ __ ] ain't that
some [ __ ] yeah you gotta be stupid
yeah like this [ __ ] wasn't the the
gunshot gunshot bad ass type of [ __ ]
yeah his ship was creative and he always
did his [ __ ] next level yeah which is
where you [ __ ] up Wes you dug that
[ __ ] down they'll be out here talented
with all of you that's like I mean even
with all of like all of us come from a
different realm of YouTube and all that
[ __ ] we've been here we've all been here
for a little while and like even I look
at videos on like Instagram some other
day and I was like we did that joke in
2009 yo that's what I'm saying man like
I've been seeing stuff from back in the
day like your sketch is my buddy
sketches my sketches and they're doing
it again again like that's mine I've
been doing yeah but it's like but you
know that I think people get influenced
from yeah I've seen in the past and they
probably don't even know yeah right and
there's no what are we gonna do just sit
here and be old man and bitter about it
I try to get in that category [ __ ] you
just you go do more that's me when
you're talented it doesn't matter cuz
you just keep creating new [ __ ] like
it's like it's easy it's easy [ __ ]
West man there's one thing though I want
to bring on this podcast cuz I do want
to talk to about this fools like new
quiet ass voice that he's been doing
yeah I know Wes you need to cut that
[ __ ] out though this was that's his
voice nah man like he I met him back in
the day yeah eight years ago I don't
know what the [ __ ] it is but he got this
whole like Jaden Smith like [ __ ] lip
bite and [ __ ] [ __ ] forehead
scrunch thing going on I was on a
podcast of my butt buddy my 10 yeah
[ __ ] talking into the mic he was
like what the [ __ ] is with your voice
brothers boys first off Wes looks like
he's 17 I don't know what type of I
don't know what type of water he's
drinking but I need to find out because
like this dude has the Fountain of Youth
secret like it's crazy
is he [ __ ] grew up in Asia that's why
that's what I get it man
as well he's five foot one a lot of
alumni age a lot of hot soups soups
going on I'm not mad at it question what
made you come up with this uh this logo
here oh so this [ __ ] right here I'm it's
well genius brain was just like phrase
or somebody used for you know someone
who always tries to act like they're
[ __ ] smart so it's really just
concert my stupid yeah so that's what
the genius brain concept is and this is
an isometric art where you kind of
create a world with him this one little
cube and so the artist that I hit up is
from Asia and paid him a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton
of money to do this yeah
no but and he kind of already knew who I
was which was dope and I just said hey
like this is what the concept is you're
the artist I want you to create whatever
you want don't even ask for my input
just oh this is what I'm tell you what I
am you know who I am
and create something that's this podcast
is gonna be about anything and
everything yeah and then and then do
what you want they created this and I
[ __ ] love it man have you still been
working out not as much as I'm on this
traveling Food Show this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
me bro I was supposed to look like you
and it didn't happen wait [ __ ] it
stuff man I tell people all the time
like they're like oh you're out there
doing it I might listen every day is a
straw it's not a it's not a get up in
like oh yeah let's let's go no it's
tough you gotta you gotta fight through
this [ __ ] like you could doing some
[ __ ] new-age workout [ __ ] oh yeah
no no you got a [ __ ] three-year-old
on your back with a rope [ __ ]
throwing it down with the trainer trader
Omar like every time we come in I'm like
he has something new and I'm like what
do you do like you just sit at home and
just like alright how about I'll ruin
somebody's life tomorrow in the gym just
got some crazy ass like racial workouts
I'll do it 12 years a slave today are we
gonna go underground right we're gonna
run through a tunnel like what we're
doing but I mean I can't even be mad cuz
like it's at 31 I'm in the best shape of
my life like when I was 21 I wasn't in
this good to shape that's the crazy part
cuz I was eating everything I was wasn't
working out stay consistent with that
[ __ ] because [ __ ] Mike and
emmanuel told me you were fat before
yeah I was fat that's [ __ ] crazy I've
never known that I was I was I look like
a I look like a lesbian
I'm a fat lesbian like I was like why
the [ __ ] how did I go from a lesbian to
a a man they told me that they told me
that they still see the fat in you
sometimes like oh absolutely
it'd just be like creeping out a little
bit I'm like yeah like that the fats
never gonna leave my heart it just left
some of my body but I'm still even wear
like bottom gut is the toughest part
like the gut like at the bottom is the
bottom gut side you got it back to in
fact it dude it was on my back fit bro
he like backed it is something that you
don't recognize somebody else man I see
I don't know what's going on this
doesn't have worth nothing worse than
somebody like somebody pointing out a
flaw but they're like kinda helping you
a little bit like I was on set one time
and this guy had an aerial shot of uh he
was doing an aerial shot for me and
before we started he was like let me
talk to you for a second he pulls it to
the side oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] like he's a
man huh when you're doing the same make
sure you keep your chin up and then he
was like I was like it's um going on
he's like yeah yeah I can see you
getting a little thin at the top I said
oh no oh no bro it's like he's helping
me but [ __ ] you I didn't want to know
that right now and that's but that's for
we were mean Emmanuel's talking about
that in the kitchen the other day he was
like being bald is fine
yeah balding is the weird that's the
weird
in-between spot so it's like either let
it go or like try to figure that [ __ ]
but here's the [ __ ] though this is what
I say is what I always say like if I
were ever to be a bald man yeah I want
to be a black bald man you know why cuz
you guys had Jordan and ever since
Jordan
yo everybody was like you know what bean
balls not that bad yeah he brought he
brought bald in because he had hair into
the league
and when he shaved it off nobody night
made an uproar it wasn't a it was like
alright this is a and he had a ball head
without a lot of facial hair yeah
and I don't trust people without a lot
of face hair I'm sorry David what are
you doing over there what's going on
with your face but not like he came in
with no facial and is like I like this
look like no you right like as a black
man if I went bald spot cuz I've had a
loaf a before and it's like I kinda
already looked kinda ball and had a
little faith with like a nice beard
alright cool but being bald in like my
dad is 57 yeah he has hair but right in
the middle where it's just thin and as I
said pops like I said man who are you
trying to impress you've been [ __ ]
the same woman yeah we was trying to
impress my life stop that's enough he
just had he had my little brother at 50
and that completely made him gray after
that I think he's just stressed it's a
child there's some people though they
identify with their hair like that's
true like it's their [ __ ] buddy of mine
from high school Hennessey this dude in
a [ __ ] minute I'm telling you right
now he's like one of those dudes that
he's been lining his hair up by himself
since we were kids and I got to tell you
something right now like just watching
him you're lying his hair like he took
off his cap when we were out in
Sacramento and we're getting some drinks
and he I saw him just take off his cap
and rub his head this [ __ ] lying
his head at the middle of his head like
bro at this point let it go so he had a
nice cold to say yes suburban hey
[ __ ] I lined it up right here
it's dead middle of his head
oh yeah like they go what are you lining
up let that [ __ ] that's it out of here
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] ridiculous and I'm
not I'm not even afraid to be bald
that's the thing I don't like the
balding process so if I start to get
crazy I'll be like all right that's
that's a dude there's no no your head is
way too big if I go [ __ ] bald man I'm
moving like a [ __ ] milk you don't
look like the Epcot Center
ya know anything is though I got a
beautiful round head like it's round
it's [ __ ] there's not a single lump but
it's like there's some people that just
don't look good bald and I am one of
them yeah I don't I couldn't see yeah I
could see your ball I know I mean you
could but I would be at a temple praying
David lately he's been over and over
with the marks just
that's a [ __ ] - because you know I've
always grew up with thin hair like okay
I have like fine hair yeah so like I
started getting worried like I'm not
getting bald yeah I'm gonna get my hair
like cut up and lined up I'm like yo no
you're good I'll let you know when it's
time like you're not gonna tell you the
truth - you ain't man like I'm not
really cutting anything I'm not time to
let it go I think what's gonna happen is
I want to get my hair cut
my mother [ __ ] just gonna be like I'm
just gonna charge you half and I'm like
why why you don't talk to me that for
it's like I just really didn't do much
water I do anything to what I was
thinking I just talked about my dad with
my little brother
can i - little brothers 1:13 and one is
about to be seven and I'm just like I'm
thinking about my dad at 57 with a 13
and a seven-year-old I was like I wonder
if he cusses ed them a lot because I
feel like I'm gonna be a Custer come on
Fisher I've been cussing a long time now
and I just can't stop I've tried I've
tried to literally be like alright you
know what for the next 72 hours I'm
gonna try not to cut and it just like
what is my favorite word I mean like
podcast does to you though it shows you
your your tendencies when you speak it
shows you how [ __ ] up you speak it
shows you how much you curse I didn't
realize how much I cursed until this
podcast man every other word is a [ __ ]
and I don't and I didn't even notice
this [ __ ] because it's just something
I've done since I was a kid and it's
like it's like where did it come play
I'm trying figure out even when I first
started like who influenced him you ever
thought about who influenced you oh I
already know whom like why I started
cursing like I started cursing because
when I was a kid I was super violent I
you see in a lot of fights okay and and
I think it was because I just always had
pent-up aggression so excited of just
punching people in the face Crouching
Tiger Hidden baby was just cursed like I
would just like verbally stress so
that's like fighting but verbally
exactly even my lady has to understand
when I'm in the car and I'm pissed off
just let me say my [ __ ] like I'm not
gonna do anything I'm not me get it out
there's let me get it out like this like
somebody comes up and cross it beyond
I'm like nobody likes to be constipated
don't know I don't hold the city
I found the [ __ ] out cuz I did this
thing called rage cage in New York we
can just bust up old printers and plates
and [ __ ] and so so satisfying yeah so
here's the [ __ ] I found out I'm not even
angry I'm a person and it's not because
I'm not an angry person here is because
I constantly let it out I don't hold
[ __ ] in no so I was I thought I broke
one thing I was like good man yeah so
you're type so if you have a
disagreement with a friend you're gonna
go ahead we're gonna talk it look one
way head let this out we're gonna figure
this out yeah you know what the friend
I'll do it very cordially if there's
nobody I don't like it's not like [ __ ]
you it's not that happen just like you
it's like you already know I don't like
you someone's gonna let you have it
there are some people in this world like
I know for a fact if they die like I
will go to that funeral just to [ __ ]
piss in their grave so they have a
little piece of me with them like
there's some [ __ ] did yeah I'm
talking about you I grew up in a
Christian household but I don't give up
that's correct man that's funny you say
that do you ever feel it's funny like
God knows my soul yeah you yeah that's
why we think you know what you know I'm
like like my you have taught the guy
like want me home aim my ate my bed like
you know I you know what I say fall I
should say this [ __ ] doubts likes me
youth minister yeah I should say this
[ __ ] all the time to my kids I was like
I know that my my relationship with God
is better than most people because I
talk to God like he's a friend yeah you
know to me like there I'll be here some
people's prayers are like dear Lord
Heavenly Father on earth and then in the
ground above and the sea below you know
what God I'm just like God why you do me
like that what come on man oh you know
you know I try to do that today like oh
man that's how it should be because if
if we're supposed to have this divine
connection of walking up like I was
taught like this to you like my whole
life it was like yo what's good
I have some of the [ __ ] worst luck on
earth and I just had that I always
talked to God just like yo come on man
like you got to give me a break
what's a bad day for you I'm talking for
like everyone I'm trying taking my mind
like what's been a day where I've been
like [ __ ] this day man I had some I mean
there was one year where just [ __ ] was
just [ __ ] crumbling right before my
eyes and I was just like you know what
God
[ __ ] up there are some people there
are murderers in this world murderer you
should be a tag you you don't act me but
that's the is because you because we had
like because we are actually really good
people
oh for sure I will say that I'm a
[ __ ] good person great people so like
I feel like it has to happen to us you
because if it happens to the people who
are terrible the world is just B it'll
just be a [ __ ] show it wasn't the Bible
was a job was he the one that had the
meteor come and crashed into his [ __ ]
farm oh it took his whole family
everything yeah and we had to figure
everything else oh yeah that that was
the stroller had to go get a job when I
heard that I said Oh everything was
taken from us and but you see these
people they always come back and this is
my alright so we're doing something
right but it's just like and I never
forget um did you watch entourage yeah
Jerry Ferrara her turtle they played
turtle yeah yeah yeah yeah he came on
our podcast god bless him to this day
and he came on our podcast a couple you
like 2015 which he didn't even have to
do first off he's stunning on this could
be pulled up in a Maserati come on we in
Italy I would keep that I would aqui
come on Jerry but on the podcast he said
one of the realest things I heard he was
like this industry is meant to break you
like it's meant to break for sure like
it's not meant to hey I wanna see you
succeed no no if you're gonna come in
here you're gonna fight it's like like
you you're going through the dungeon of
you know the emboss levels and game you
have to keep going but you gotta fight
each level I try to help you at all time
like when you come to Hollywood or you
come out here thinking you want to be a
podcast or an actor or commit whatever
it is
Oh get ready like and I will wrap up man
like Hollywood don't owe you [ __ ] know
you they don't know you should that's
why when people walk away and they're
upset at these auditions that they don't
get I understand what you're going to be
yes it's rough it's tough but just keep
it in your back pocket to know that they
don't owe you anything
they really don't and they whatever [ __ ]
that you've been through they've also
been through a to the so they're already
pretty jaded yeah and acting in and of
itself is already a tough part that's
like that's tough you it's such an
emotional you got to be so vulnerable in
every man dude that's why comedy is
great for us because even though low-key
like when you think about [ __ ] Jim
Carrey yeah phenomenal actor which I
didn't figure out until later in life I
was like this dude can really act I'm
telling you right now like what I'm
finding out about this space is that I
feel that I'm not weird enough to be six
the weirdest [ __ ] I'm talking
about some weird-ass [ __ ] that
I've met yeah they are the most
successful human beings yeah they're
[ __ ] weird like in in a one-on-one
interaction I'm like I don't [ __ ] with
you I wouldn't hang out with you but
your art is crazy because you're [ __ ]
insane yeah like nobody is on your
wavelength yeah you know I'm saying like
Jim Carrey he's [ __ ] weird up he's a
master painter like his man paints like
what the [ __ ] is that word an eggcup
this fool is over here he's like he's
like when those like Kim Possible shits
he's like on this [ __ ] like strapped up
above a canvas and he's floating and
he's painted like come on bro and it's a
beautiful tree like what is this like
who are you and it's like but do we have
do we all have that to tap into I was
like art painting for me it's a [ __ ]
show oh yes my art in school I didn't
even want to draw because like this [ __ ]
looks like I've vomited on the paper so
I was so lazy I had my best friend on
here and back in the day we uh we we had
this math project we're supposed to
eight there's like game board yeah i i'm
so bad at [ __ ] art or anything that
that type of sense we went to Home Depot
and we got these like paint sample cards
and use that as tiles around the game
board because we don't want to paint it
ourselves and we thought that she'd get
a la Polly I think I played them before
somebody stole that idea back see that's
my life got a wobbly but now it's like I
just I wasn't a drawer I wasn't a pen
I'm suffering when I figured out what I
could do like I was trying fair what
gray was I mean where I was like well I
know I always had music in my backpack
because I started playing trumpet first
that was my first instrument trumpet and
so I went from trumpet to like
percussion to like the drum line and
sorry music is there and I started
rapping like eighth grade and I was like
alright music there but I've never seen
myself full on comedy or none like that
it wasn't until I met the guys it's like
sometimes I feel like you meet people
that have to pull I have the pool [ __ ]
out of you because you it's hard for us
to look at ourselves all right what what
can I do good some I have to be like my
have some [ __ ] in there like and I feel
like that's just science from the
universe you know and just like hey you
might have the Chabad and I've never
seen myself
la doing comedy fool done that's why I
don't man when I hear some people's
stories like these highly successful
noodle and they said that they've been
able to conceptualize and envision what
they wanted since day one I don't know
what that's like I don't know Anna so I
like when when I go to these college
shows and I think that's the answer that
they want from me like they almost had
this preconceived like thought uh-oh
David so how did you get to where you're
at what was that moment they want to
hear the story of you know when I was a
kid
like I was taking a [ __ ] in my diaper
and I was like yo man I'm gonna be a nun
median because you know life [ __ ] and I
gotta make it fun and I got a rat so do
you think some of those are [ __ ] cuz
it's kind of weird not [ __ ] but it's
like you mean to tell me like you like
you knew like you might have known I can
be subtle I I feel like I could be like
you but you knew what like yeah and like
maybe it's just because people are
different I think that when you become a
multi facet of human being yeah
basically what I'm saying is I'm [ __ ] at
a lot of things like I just sampled why
different and I've been really bad at a
lot of things like I think that it
becomes hard for me to be focused on
that singular thing because my life goal
isn't to be just an entertainer I just
want to be happy and I'm trying to
fulfill whatever that is to fill this
goal of being man it doesn't matter what
it is man so when people say to me you
know what happened what would happen if
you know I don't know like YouTube
explodes I was like YouTube explodes and
life moves on life moves on I work at a
chick-fil-a I don't know like some you
know is some people that if Instagram
was to go down today it's a rock you see
that one [ __ ] girl it was like a few
months ago where I guess like her
account got deleted or some she went
nuts this [ __ ] I would have thought she
had [ __ ] chemo bligh Satomi
stage for 1314 cancer dude like from
hemoglobin fights automa like maybe you
could see through her stomach I knew
what I thought a tumor was coming out of
her [ __ ] like this [ __ ] was just like
I can't do anything else like I don't
have any other skills I'm like we'll get
some skills yesterday it's the
difference between doing something for
living and doing something that's you
passionate about because if I'm
passionate about
entertained being happy comedy then if
everything's goes down alright I guess
I'll just pull up to a club on Santa
Monica making some [ __ ] animal like
hey did that make you laugh which i
think is a [ __ ] crazy talent the
balloons balloons crazy it's great like
who thought I'm gonna make some [ __ ]
animal that is looking so [ __ ] up
though like I don't know what it is
about me yeah that makes me hate magic
so much you hate magic
like [ __ ] that come up got a
black heart do you have magic I hate
magic with a passion I don't know what
it is and I'm not sure that I hate magic
I think I hate people who approach me
and then try to do magic without me
asking you know they go you hate
[ __ ] so I went to this Magic Castle
thing if you haven't been in Magic
Castle it's just literally this castle
where they're just a bunch of magicians
and all these magician shows in there
and you know Tim loves that [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] but so my
girlfriend at the time yeah she brought
me there and she was like yo I'm gonna
take you to Magic Castle bla bla bla and
you know for me what I figured out in a
relationship was that even if I don't
like something yeah I will enjoy the
moment with you
because you enjoy it not because I don't
like it right yeah so I went there and
then you know right off the bat just
come in this guy's just like you pick a
card any card
I'm like I will [ __ ] stab you get the
[ __ ] away from because but okay you
can't walk into somebody's lair and that
thing like I know it was just like the
worst situation ever and I'm just
sitting here just I'm not I'm impressed
that they could do this [ __ ] right yeah
it's just a weird thing maybe not in
that Magic Castle situation but I'm just
at a party just chillin having a drink
there's somebody's like I do magic I'm
like that's [ __ ] funny I could
[ __ ] care less what's your name
jackass
that's that's that's one thing I that
pisses me off but we're chilling and you
automatically either ask me what I do or
tell me what you do and I don't even
know like I don't know who are you it's
like a youtuber who comes up to a girl
and she's like oh do you know I'm on
YouTube it's the same [ __ ] it's like I
don't I don't what the [ __ ] how's that
your intro yeah
you are a dick like what was this I
don't give a [ __ ] like all right I'm on
board I don't know what you like like
everything he does is magic - it'll be
like Oh what's your name he goes I don't
know look at the back of the car okay I
will fight I'm gonna [ __ ] fish I'm a
build a time machine so I can go back in
time to find the moment you found magic
and I'ma burn those cars but what did
that is everybody has to be seen
everyone has to be seen it's like we
don't have you remember like I was
talking to the guys on the podcast a
couple weeks ago about this remember
like I don't know like some people we
just knew people in even in your
neighborhood and they even in your
community yeah you might go to a
neighbor and be like oh hey what's up
like you just talk nobody has to know
about it you just talk you go now I just
feel like somebody it's always a show as
hey you know you - did you know like yo
yo miss out like what's wrong do that
phrase that was poppin off as like a
[ __ ] video it didn't happen yeah you
know I mean I'm like why why hey like
that's the weird [ __ ] - it's like all
this like weird [ __ ] happens to me in LA
there but I'm so busy trying to
experience it and then try to figure out
like something funny about it
I don't whip out my phone and then sure
I'm like ah Sh
but in my mind - I'm like [ __ ] maybe I
should have recorded it but at the time
like I don't think about things I'm
thinking about it it's not our
generation - [ __ ] whip out a phone
and record everything that's popping up
next generation [ __ ] yeah for sure it's
like if you didn't record we're like the
guinea pigs
well we're like the experimental stage
they don't do tests on us and probably
all the people who are all on Instagram
on in like 50 years and they gonna buy
all their brains
yeah it's fried out here sometimes it's
hard for me because I like I started
doing like back in the day I remember I
started doing daily vlogging and that
[ __ ] was great it was doing really well
I love that [ __ ] and I did it cuz I
enjoyed it but then when I started to
realize when I was on these vacations
and I was recording everything every day
that's the only thing I could remember
was what I saw through the screen and
not what I saw with my eyes and now you
can't even be a good storyteller yeah
like I don't
okay like be and that's that we we have
to be story to like [ __ ] like this
talking for hour hour and a half you got
to be able to tell story carry
conversation but if we're always here
then our lens is literally this is it
like this is all we guinness like what
happened to like campfire story that's
why they were so good cuz you'd be like
oh [ __ ] what happened next
alright Emma
I would love to see like a bunch of 15
year-olds go camping now without the
rooms and so I should be we battle
royale [ __ ] would die I want to
do that [ __ ] I want to come in here just
knock these kids out and then leave one
bone what they do that [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm not saying any better either
because like I think I might feel a
little a certain way to know for sure
yeah but you're gonna figure it out
because we found we come from and it
like we come from playing outside by the
way we played outside weed alike we're
gonna figure this [ __ ] out but they
would be in a panic and a complete panic
this podcast is brought to you by Ray
Khan hey guys are you walking around
with earbuds all day with wires on it
well what are you doing dummy you got to
get on that wireless game man but I know
for a fact that wireless earbuds can be
really really expensive or the
inexpensive ones just they aren't
cutting it well have you heard of rake
on my friends rake on earbuds is the
earbuds of my choice and it's the one
that I've been using and it's wireless
I love wireless earbuds man I need
wireless when I walk around especially
when I'm working out and I got a wire in
my face no siree
you already know rake on earbuds start
at about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
and they sound just as amazing as other
top audio brands you know and Ray cons
latest model the e25 is their best one
yet with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are very comfortable perfect for
on-the-go listening n for taking phone
calls my friends unlike some of other
wireless options rate con earbuds are
both stylish and discreet with no
dangling wires or stems and you've heard
me talk about how the company was
co-founded by Ray J and celebrities my
friends such as snoop d-o-double-g and
you know if uncle snoops own debt it
gots to be dope they're obsessed with
break-ins so make sure you guys pick up
a pair and see what the hype is about
now is the time to get the latest and
greatest from Ray con get 50% off your
order at buy rake on Comm
slash brain that's buy rake on Comm
slash brain for 15% off rake on wireless
ear
by Ray con-com / brain cop yourself a
pair of these because I use them on a
daily and I really do enjoy him like I
love camping because like I think I
enjoy cooking a lot so of course but I
well we go camp me the first thing I
talk about my will we go eat hey would
you say everyday I say the same food you
get done doing something alright so what
we brother your yes
most of my money when I know I get on on
them and I'm making it it's gonna go to
food food yeah I told the guy I remember
I said well sir I was like I don't think
my kitchens gonna see me for a long time
cuz I'm not gonna want to [ __ ] go in
there because once you got a money like
more to come to me like I don't like
that's even though the process of
cooking can be fun I think it but you
only gonna do that here in mayor like
remember back in the days when [ __ ] an
appetizer wasn't even option no it's
like hey would you like an appetizer
would you like a drink no not no would
you like a pie be thirsty as [ __ ] here
like this give me the food my [ __ ] was
this like either I get this sprite or
you get a tip so so much years ago [ __ ]
you tell me dude which reminds me
yesterday me and Micah ride in the car
and we're talking about how this is
thing with people nowadays it's women
and men but it's a lot of women they
have the most unread text I've ever seen
in my life like one of my friends says
she had 800 unread because a [ __ ] got
[ __ ] options that's why [ __ ]
I don't got off I tell girls to sleep
send me their screenshot it's [ __ ] 405
what the [ __ ] are y'all doing what first
off you being a [ __ ] now you being rude
like what's wrong answer but niblet oh
well you know I just be forgetting
something no no no you don't forget it's
not an email [ __ ] and so then I'm like
but then they'll go online and complain
Oh nobody is giving me attention but
then they say but it's not the attention
that I
one but then they'll be like I want to
go out on a date take me out to eat or
something
I'm a micro like you know what this take
me out to each it has to stop yeah
because it's like if if we were having
real conversation so say I meet a girl
let's say I do something that people
don't like doing I call you instead of
texting you the whole time yeah we have
conversations we can't we converse for
of a week and I'm like you know what I
found out that she is in the fitness I
found out you found out so now the
baseline isn't going out to eat yeah now
we can actually go do something you know
I'm saying we can go go do an activity
all this [ __ ] why don't you take me
out to eat you just hungry don't go eat
go on some real you want to hear some
[ __ ] [ __ ] so Tim told me this story
where he had a home girl that was on
Twitter yeah and she put out this tweet
like I would just like I don't
paraphrasing by the way that's exactly
what she said but there's something
along the lines of I just missed those
days when like when some people just
text you a good morning right and then
Tim say oh she just wants a good morning
so by the phone in the morning said hey
good morning and then she wrote back
what's up he's like you I was like no
I'm just saying good morning because you
said that you would like she goes okay
whatever and I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like like why'd you put that [ __ ] up
then this is not satisfying what do you
want what the [ __ ] do you want what do
you want like is that this whole ghost
thing finish like but yo somebody's
showing you interest if you don't like
them just say hey look I'm not
interested right now yeah that's it and
I'll be honest with you two ones
sometimes people said like yo I'm a
little too busy I know people who are
busy and who aren't right I know people
when they're legit I understand it's
like I get it some other people when you
say you're busy you know for a fact that
you're not because if it was if it was
something really important that you
wanted you would respond yeah and that
and that's just fast you know I mean and
my thing is to it's like I don't people
don't even have to respond to me
immediately no I have no like you can
respond five six hours later that's mine
just give me a response you know and
then this is this thing where they'll
try to pick up a conversation like a day
or something later dog I will [ __ ] him
yo what type of roots is
I would at least be like hey yo I'm
sorry my day yesterday was why and I am
so sorry what's going on how can I
they just hey what's good i text you
five days ago what the [ __ ] what do you
doing stop doing that to people man like
this wild to me there's a [ __ ] girl I
know this [ __ ] I literally stopped
talking to her in general just because
her text responses were so [ __ ]
delayed and late it pissed me off
because the [ __ ] was ugly - so I'm like
who the [ __ ] you know I mean like you
gotta understand Wow yeah you gotta come
down like he come down a little bit the
funny thing was it was more likely but
it's more like I wouldn't respond back
to her text because it became habitual
that I was like oh you're not somebody
that's on the priority respond list
because you don't really respond back to
my text so I'll respond to it when I
might not to be spiteful it's just more
like you're not that important because
if clearly like you're too busy or so
yeah yeah so I'll respond to it whenever
but when I met up with her in person she
goes thanks for responding back to my
texts and I said whoa with what the
[ __ ] sharp T I don't what what
nothing what do you mean she goes she's
like texted you about this thing and you
didn't hit me back up I'm like oh it's
and I literally said to his to her face
I go that's because you are not a
priority in my life I was like you when
I was when i text you you don't respond
back she goes well I get busy well [ __ ]
I was busy - then what the [ __ ] be what
do you mean here's the thing I'm okay
with being busy yeah that's all good
being busy and being rude are two
different things yeah there's two
different things if we do a lot of [ __ ]
I know we do a lot of [ __ ] we do a lot
of [ __ ] we're bouncing around I'm coming
here to Pike house I gotta go home I got
edit stuff but in between time if I see
a message and I'm like alright I know I
got to get back to that there's gonna be
a downtime in my day where I could be
like hey I was a little busy earlier
what's going on yeah that's all I'm not
tripping that's all I want like it's a
respect thing like especially you gave
me your yeah you're the one that allowed
me to contact you right so here let me
give it back then since you [ __ ] need
it light and it's it's just weird so
like we met when Mike's it is I'll say
that makes sense why does dinner have to
equate a first date like why does that
have to be [ __ ] it let's go get some tea
let's talk over tea that's like those
type of happens or like some gay
abbis that would I realize because I
know I still do that I didn't realize
was like a like a like a ghetto person
yeah like a good thing right
I still do this [ __ ] where I get a bill
and I you know they send the bill like
20 days before it's due but if I wait to
the last yeah right right in their
pocket that [ __ ] right before I get a
notice that it's a delinquent [ __ ]
bill I didn't really sound like a ghetto
person thing you know I'm like yo how
long can i push his example try really
trying to keep this 2,000 awesome yeah
how long can i really cuz that [ __ ] adds
up man [ __ ] man and it what's the worst
it's feeling like you pay a bill and
then it comes right back around you like
yo did not just try to get my [ __ ] on
autopay so it's like nevermind out of
sight cuz I don't want to physically hit
that button that this money's gonna get
out of doing piss me off
I hate that I wish I don't have to pay
taxes dude yo I really don't [ __ ] that
I've done jobs out here and I look at
the tax and I'm like they were y'all on
set with me yeah but with who you taking
400 and something battle-ax like what
the [ __ ] is going on I've seen that MTV
check is oh man I was like yo taxes are
why I didn't then you got it if you got
if you got a team you gotta figure out
the percentages of that and I'm reading
all the stuff they took out there like
for medical just occasionally bucking if
I lose it like let me lose a leg give me
the money I'll take my field like yeah
you give me the option to not have that
service you know what I'm sayin that
[ __ ] they're like oh that [ __ ] was a
huge part of the check I'm like [ __ ]
that dude
if I get shot that's on me that's that's
natural selection is what it is yeah it
is what it is question so you're in a
relationship
mmm-hmm you are you're not engaged in I
am engaged you are engaged education
okay nevermind um so this is funny
has your sex drive gone here or here
since you've been like as you're getting
older well how do you feel your sex
drive is bigger that's a funny question
so like I'm not sure if it's the moving
in thing
I swear I swear to god this is I don't
know what it is I'm not sure if there's
some science behind this year my sex
drive was higher when I was fatter than
I am now interesting
I don't know it's because I just didn't
move so whenever I would [ __ ] that was
the only spend the energy like I don't
know the sex I got a science behind that
[ __ ] but when I was fat I was way more
near interesting it might be because
just because I'm acting I'm doing the
best thing you'd look but but also do
you feel I could be scheduled then my
ticket cuz you're not thinking about say
I feel like when we weren't doing ass
but not saying we weren't never doing
nothing but we weren't as busy or trying
to figure life out or always in our head
it was either like sports [ __ ] or like
we're just thinking about sake but I
feel like as we're doing stuff or we
could just get some old-ass nutsack
swears just not as you know because I
remember we were younger a [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hate this [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
no reason boners are [ __ ] that's why we
got a song called no reason there you go
my dick is hard for no reason did you be
like why the [ __ ] I'm watching paper
mache or something like what what am I
gonna swing you're a kid when you get a
no reason boner and that's when you
start thinking am i gay because you
would just be watching football and also
you dick come up and I'm like no I did
not find those men if I never try but
what's going on like it just wants to
salute like I'm like you better sit the
[ __ ] down there was there was not an
American flag in sight it's like but I'm
realizing like I'm listening to like
certain podcast stuff and like some
women to be like yeah I need rounds and
I'm like rounds first off no that's
first off you're gonna get a solid round
if it's a good day you know let me get
it what you mean rounds [ __ ] what is
this the UFC you hope like let me by
gonna do listen let me get a sandwich
relax a little bit we could come back
but right back out of a listen I gotta
be extra high he's got to be on another
level of horny see this is what I found
out when we were you know ever since the
internet you start reading up [ __ ] about
women and say oh [ __ ] they get multiple
orgasms oh absolutely
like for us it's like it's it might be a
UFC match looks like we hit around I
need that [ __ ] 60-second break in
between and then we might be able to go
back to it nail it comes off the rebound
but it that [ __ ] isn't right back
whoo-hoo we're never gonna get a rebound
okay that's it I'm like y'all but it's
made it's like the only thing that's
specifically made for pleasure yeah it's
like I can't compete with that
like what I'm not gonna work
specifically only take [ __ ] boxing
classes just like the [ __ ] all right
it's so complex down there
I was telling a girl that was like it's
a lie it's like the [ __ ] are you a
confident person in the way you [ __ ]
somebody though because I've never I've
never been that confident in the sense
of this like I'm not gonna lie first
time sex is so nervous for me I am cuz I
mean like I don't know what they am in
my head and I'm like how do we prevent
that do we talk but then you don't want
to talk about it a lot cuz you're like
now I'm sound like a creep
yeah and but it's like but I kind of
need to find out stuff about you so I
can figure out what you like because
it's gonna be awkward sometimes talk
about the dick game as if like their
master golden plan fits for every
[ __ ] vagina and I'm like that's not
possible it's not [ __ ] possible that
possible like I just don't understand
that part because you know before I was
in a search relationship on the show we
hook up with people here I'm just like
okay how do i tackle this [ __ ] you know
I mean you like you looking at like a
professor is looking at a problem on the
board you see that that [ __ ]
Instagram filter all the numbers you're
looking at it goes just like all right
this all right I know that I've been in
here before yeah but this is just a
different store only way rearrange them
like the Ralph's or the Trader Joe's
like wait a minute this is the milk was
down here
that [ __ ] store it is different now
you just had to be drunk as [ __ ] but
even that's a little tough though cuz
you can't call it like I've been man the
first time I didn't get up was the scare
have you ever been in that position
whiskey dick yes yes that [ __ ] will [ __ ]
you up man I didn't know what whiskey
dick was I thought
I thought much it was broken yeah you
like okay cuz you're like I'm horny like
I feel like I feel like I could do
something I found about whiskey dick
through like a sitcom they were making a
joke about it yeah and then is that some
[ __ ] because you know your boys don't
ever talk about this you don't talk
about we talk about all of our accolades
and how how good we are as [ __ ] and that
was always the awkward kid because I
didn't have sex till I was 18
yeah but everybody in my group was
[ __ ] when they were like 14 13 ya
know I've known ya I'm like yo yo yo so
they were talking about [ __ ] but I would
just sit in the corner
yeah man [ __ ] feels just like that you
know I had no idea it's like a nice like
warm mitten
yeah you have a [ __ ] take like that
[Laughter]
flower out the pie that puts a dick in
the soil you know that [ __ ] forty old
virgin in that in the beginning [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was me man yep yet he feels
like a bag don't because whereas that's
the [ __ ] fucked-up part about young
guys whereas we're so scared to be like
hey I haven't had sex yet you're gonna
get [ __ ] roasted why why am I getting
roasted cuz y'all out here do it having
sex I want you to just help me like hey
this is like this is what it is but
you're afraid to say we did a
vulnerability with men just don't go
together yeah don't go together yeah but
if a dude I think this is I mean I think
people nowadays they're a lot more
vulnerable yeah yeah you know I think in
our generation and then we go all even
older like I feel like if you were
vulnerable you're gonna have a heart
attack like I couldn't do it they would
just die on the spot they talk about the
feelings they were just [ __ ] down is
bad that was it yeah my I say this all
the time my father has never said I'm
sorry to me my mom's one my mom has
never said I'm sorry she doesn't even
know what that word means it's just
tough love
yeah and that's what we grow up have it
and then we get with somebody and
they're like why are you being my [ __ ]
you're like you know what I don't know
let me figure yeah I need to figure that
out like is why is a vein popping out he
had when you have to say I'm sorry are
you okay like but no I was I like I I
definitely am NOT I've had the
whiskey-dick before but the first the
very first time it happened to me I was
with I was I think I was overly excited
and nervous
ah which is a whole nother level because
it was a girl that I was asked I was
like 20
- I was after her after and she wouldn't
give me no time of day and then one day
she calls me out my sleep and it's like
hey what's going on and I'm uh hello
she's like oh I'm leaving the club huh
could I come by I'm immediately excited
yeah yeah yeah that's fine like I'm not
I'm up like yeah whatever they had a pep
talk with hey [ __ ] about the
hello then I hang up the phone
I hop in the shower I'm shocked I'm
still [ __ ] sleepy I just got walking
out on my sleeves I'm not alright [ __ ]
all right get it together she's coming
she gets there she looks good I'm all
right we get excited we in there we
kissing gotta die
I put the condom on and she said you a
good man you hit that [ __ ] wrong that's
night I think that's nice
bruh that's the ultimate debate for me
it's just like cuz you you shouldn't
always use all the protection always
protect your trash honest about it here
use it because it's safe but let's
really be honest about it here - it is
it's not natural useful to go on there
now just like every time I had that [ __ ]
I'm just like you [ __ ] you
better goddamn I don't know about this
[ __ ] I'm like I don't know about this
and I'm always just just right every man
has been in this position right here
you're about to have sex the condom is
right there and you're looking at her
she's looking at you you try to figure
out all right cuz if I just about to go
in here it's two things gonna happen she
could be like hey what the [ __ ] are you
doing or she could just let me go but I
know for sure that's the safest route
over there yeah every guy's been ever
since we like or when you get in there
raw and you like I shouldn't be doing
you know what's dope though so it's like
if you're if when you were about to [ __ ]
and the girls it's like hey you need to
use a condom cuz I don't really know you
like that I'm like oh that means you're
clean and I'm like I'm clean I'm clean
as [ __ ] yeah yeah like I just got tested
it's like don't we're both good you know
but that conversation never goes out too
well and you
yeah yeah yeah the reason why she stays
clean reason why you stay clean because
using the content use a kind of if it's
real [ __ ] you know what you know what a
condom is condom is like eating halo ice
cream you know it's like it's good for
what it does you know I mean but it's
not the same as ice cream like I [ __ ]
with hail alive yeah because I just like
every vegan option yeah that's exactly
pretty solid so this is dope but I know
would you like it impossible but yeah I
know the imposter gonna taste good but
ain't no regular burger yeah if I old
they're very confident when I was a
youth minister some of these kids be so
[ __ ] funny man like I remember skate
came up to me he took me aside and goes
you know no pads can I ask you something
you know I just I really want to have
sex you know like I have this girl that
I like you know but is it wrong if I
just have sex once and then I repent and
not have I was like let me take
something much out yeah
once you get in there you're never gonna
want to come out yeah you're gonna
realize how trash your hand is compared
to a [ __ ] like you will never ever go
that you're never that's that's because
that's home for us we came from there
yeah that's awesome you're the kid that
went it you went to Afghanistan and then
you get that you came back home you're
coming back home and you wanted to
welcome you come here like oh yeah it
hugs you yeah like it's so awesome I was
like remember before [ __ ] you were you
know all about just like fun kid [ __ ]
who's living life eat a pizza with your
friends you know I'm saying like go to
school the minute you have [ __ ] your
life starts to just knock every [ __ ]
before I had [ __ ] they start to go down
here to read but what's the book now you
open the book you let old [ __ ] opens
but what I do is I take an aloe plant
again I slice it in half and I believe
the middle it's really true like like
you cuz that wasn't once you have it man
as a young man our hormones go
man I don't miss that [ __ ] no no no that
was great that is all you thought about
like wake up in the morning [ __ ]
go to bed that's all you do you like
what is wrong with me like there's some
there's some people who - by the way
that we're questionably number one
unattractive at all all accounts yeah
it's physically personality-wise but the
fact that she just had a [ __ ] and I was
like you know what she puppies went
through a lot of [ __ ] you know and then
you know you start rationalizes grow you
just start rationalizing that [ __ ] just
be sure so [ __ ] yeah I've been so horny
that I've just been like I know I don't
like you like I know I don't like you I
know if I was not horny I would not be
here
I would not text you I wouldn't talk to
you I'm pretty - like young girls do
they get horny but they're like I think
it's just more shameful for a girl to
talk about that yeah that's depending on
who it is cuz I know girls who I [ __ ]
me and I'm just thinking like damn what
were you thinking cuz I I came in
flip-flops and socks and that's the [ __ ]
outfit yeah if I pull up on you in some
flops pogs little Jim short of them no
he's gonna come around right Oh cuz I
was a big boy and not only was I a big
boy I did I gave a [ __ ] about what I
look like and so it was you know and
that's what made you attract new you
can't give a [ __ ] he that's a weird
thing to I think women are so much more
cerebral than men absolutely
they couldn't date there are qualities
and men that they'll like about you
that'll make you physically attractive
and guys are just they're so [ __ ]
primal yeah you know what I mean because
I was like we honestly we we actually
tried to not be and it don't work late
it works sometime but a lot of times
like you just look good like I say this
[ __ ] to like some of those girls who
touch me I just want to see them again
just wanna get some depth it's like
thanks I appreciate you appreciate good
without that I would I would kill them
during that time I went through a [ __ ]
drought and you filled up my wallet I
was done with my books and allô allô
wasn't feeling the same woman told me
the other day she was like I don't like
this thing where men have to feel like
they have to be like oh I love your
energy because your Mystere and I just
love them
you don't know just tell me you I look
good because right because I can feel
you bullshitting me like so now if a
girl's like what made you talk to me I'm
literally I'm not gonna lie I thought
you were a
tractive coz what am I gonna live for
and be like well you know I just like I
felt something see my eyebrows [ __ ] man
you look you look good like and but now
we can get the noise you like I that was
the I'm I don't like this thing where
people be like oh yeah I don't see the
physical yes you do [ __ ] the [ __ ] yes
my hey listen I hate that [ __ ] because
there's nothing wrong with fighting
somebody physically it's nothing wrong
there's a lot of things that develop
afterwards but that initial reaction
it's it's your eyes how your voice
sounds or some [ __ ] right cuz I mean I
do understand that to a certain extent
where for me I feel like a lot of the
girls that I find really attractive yeah
are ones that who I vibe with yeah I
don't know what it is maybe cuz I'm a
little jaded but every time I see a
overly attractive woman on your side you
ain't got no personality that's the
first thing I think about and you don't
want a baby yeah you know but that's
more of like a defense mechanism on my
part
yeah make me feel to buy this woman
would I don't even want to talk to you
yeah yeah I mean which is a lie I want I
want to lay butt-naked and I want to put
my nose in that ass right in the crease
and just wiggling around I want to die
in there you ever just look at a woman
I've know every man's men we just
looking at her and you're like I would
lick every doctor she has that my buddy
says the funniest [ __ ] dude he goes like
I want this woman to take a bath so I
could take a bath water yeah just just
drink it up just drink it
it's like I would just suck on you but
just to back the back part of your
quarter-second history that's why those
Instagram girls they understand what
they're working for it because they
understand there are men out there that
would literally drink their baths
literally if they told them to literally
I know a home road right now she gets
requests to [ __ ] like step on dudes
balls I will never understand that I
want that I don't judge anybody for
their sexual preference that I do but
yes why the [ __ ] would I want to be in
pain like that people are sensitive yo
they talk about some [ __ ] where I feel
like some of these dudes are they're so
[ __ ] up mentally because they're at
the top of their game like they're
the CEO of this year that they need to
feel dominated because they haven't felt
that experience and it makes them feel
alive because everything is given to
them so what they want you to do is take
a machete a slice up their [ __ ]
ballsack weird [ __ ] wild to me I've had
a girl go like to my balls and I'm like
oh what the [ __ ] why would you do this
I got ticklish ballsacks dude so say
yeah I thought I was the only one I'm
digging I'm giggled dog first figure
this out is when I was hooking up with
this one Filipino girl and she was the
more like sexually experienced one
because she was six or seven years older
than me okay she was doing some [ __ ] to
me that no other girl has ever yeah so
you're in the world I was in a new world
so I remember like this is the first
time I ever got my balls suck right and
then I felt like a little [ __ ] because
I didn't enjoy it as much because I saw
that [ __ ] in porn and do it again
they're they're balls tucked and their
[ __ ] dick jack oh yeah you're like oh
there's got to be a tickle tickle and my
ladies were super straight and she
thought I was enjoying it it's like no
[ __ ] tickle tickle so much sometime
yeah you like that I was like not really
good but you know I mean I can but it's
like I don't you watch I just want to
slap her upside of hit ball sucking
tickles man right now that should tickle
but then it low-key it fit I mean it
feels good yeah but it tickles like this
should take not sure if it feels good
just because it feels good or does it
feel good because of some some crazy
[ __ ] because sometimes it's visual I
think yeah I think that's what anything
is visual like I think a lot of sex for
men while some men may come faster light
like if I'm getting really good hair I'm
not I can't look at you oh yeah because
it's a wrap
it's gonna come out of it right so that
in order for me then I'm like I don't I
don't look at you because it's like
we're visual creatures so we saying they
would like in this ego [ __ ] was I
looking at a hot pocket in microwave
he's gotta look away for a second
would you bake uh something turned a
little oven like you like why do I keep
you in hungry [ __ ] turn you look good
doing it my dick is in I can't look
anymore
Hey Oh what's funny is I don't know why
I find this funny but like anyway he's
like tell me when you call me really all
right I go do it the face that's made a
man my bad I didn't my fault
now you would be porn is the funniest
[ __ ] thing to me nowadays when I was
younger first of all we were younger we
got to look at porn that [ __ ] was a
journey we had to find that we had to
find a neighborhood kid that would steal
Playboy's give him a quarter for a page
and then we would have to use our
imagination to jack off so then when we
finally got to VHS and DVDs were like oh
[ __ ] we're making moves we're regars try
but then you got to make sure you get it
to the right part you got a fast for it
that's a lot of [ __ ] work you kids
are privileged nowadays you guys I just
go straight like if whenever I watch
porn I just go straight to the last two
minutes and I'm like I don't I don't
need all that extra [ __ ] I just want to
see what she'd like my black story I
don't need that [ __ ] my story like store
[ __ ] this ain't [ __ ] James Cameron I
don't write this [ __ ] need like
a Adam morphix I want to see the meat
like not granite bangbus that I used to
watch it was kind of cool because my are
they picking them up asking fantasy that
but it's fantasy day you want to get
picked up by a porn star and be like hey
would you like your dick sucked it's
like absolutely yes I would not that
camera because it's gonna fall down it's
immediately I'm not I can't I can't I
can't even record myself bugging I get
nervous oh man I've record myself it's
not good oh no for sure
it's a terrible thing a little bit like
when the guys see their own sex face
it's like is that what I look like when
I'm humping I look like an S like I'm
like the letter S what I watch my body
shape if you look like that you all are
they ate grass rock humping that way and
what the [ __ ] is that on my ass
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] is not attractive and then you
start looking at her at weight she
enjoyed this I don't remember her not
making noise during this real [ __ ] but a
lot of a lot of sex is ego though a lot
of a lot of this 100% man I think being
comfortable enough to communicate to
somebody what you like it dislike is
very important so that girl that was
like really sexual you know they're
doing all second of [ __ ] she was
actually the first one to tell me how
bad I was at having sex and I didn't
[ __ ] I did a video on this a while ago
but I think I literally asked her like
oh god there was a moment well here
[ __ ] and she was one of those I
verbally verbally aggressive women right
so she was just like who's like she's
like whose [ __ ] is this doc I will
remember this forever it was the most
mortifying experience of my life because
she was like whose [ __ ] is this I went
yours yours dawg
the most mortifying experience of my
life cuz the funniest part about that is
that is the correct answer is because I
don't it is yours
yeah I'm his next it's not technically
mine you were going at it from a
tentacles from a very technical aspect
yeah I just
she was so turned off as that she goes
no that's not what you're supposed to
say I'm like but it is yours right like
you can't fault me for me for that one
that's just some [ __ ] [ __ ] facts
drink come out of a wine glass for me
what dog that [ __ ] was abused by her
father her uncle and her grandfather
that said [ __ ] what type of fine-dining
do you really like what type of [ __ ] is
that me so funny she just drinks come
out of glass and we're like well you
want to go eat some McDonald's I don't I
just don't come out you think I'm gonna
eat I was like but here's the thing they
goes better with Dave Chappelle said you
could tell the tune to come in a fish
tank he's gonna come in there it don't
matter where it goes she was like you
can't you come in this wine go
absolutely yeah why not salutely because
this is coming out of me
this point I don't care where it goes
I'm sorry III laughs issued so much dude
if a girl told me to come into a wine
glass I would laugh so hard as I'm
coming dude and that [ __ ] would be hard
to aim billing you a little oh yeah
that's funny
that is hilarious it's so weird because
when I meet it when you know when you
meet girls like that [ __ ] it's like damn
I would [ __ ] you but I would not bring
you home I don't think you've something
that bring to my mom yeah you definitely
nice time at dinner and my moms like you
want some wine
oh [ __ ] no mom no no no yeah it's like
like white like guys and girls have like
side chicks and side dudes because
there's some dudes and girls that you
want to keep around for the rest of your
life in love but you definitely don't
want them to do the [ __ ] that you want
to do to them do you know what I'm
saying no that's true it's like I love
you so much I'm not going to tell you
I'm not gonna come in and come in your
mouth but this other girl I would I
would definitely surprise comes out her
all all day you know how to me because I
would do disgust because she doesn't
respect me and I don't respect her but I
respect the [ __ ] out of you so I would
never do that [ __ ] to you that's what
that [ __ ] is funny that is that's what
those sites are yeah yeah I love my kids
I love my family I'm a good father
because the guy gets I guess or the guy
or girl whoever is doing the cheating
they get into this redundant pattern
yeah and it goes back to communication
they don't they're afraid to just say
hey something's a little off I think we
should explore some different things
yeah like even if you ought to go to a
sex club yeah nothing you got to have
sex weed with everybody else you could
just be in the environment as sexy what
it does explore that I think people are
just afraid to talk to each other when
they're going through something that's
the but that's the main part of being in
relations with somebody you should be
able to talk to them so instead they're
like alright you tripping a little bit
so i'ma go over here and do disgusting
things to her I've been I've been so
tired one time like like I was so
[ __ ] horny but I was so exhausted I
just looked over at the girls like I'm
just gonna put my hand on you kid and
see if something happens I'm tired and
she was exhausted too I just put my hand
on [ __ ] and then we were like no do you
know we are probably more tired a lot of
people because we use this all the
[ __ ] time man so it's draining by the
time you do you like
oh [ __ ] I've been having podcast go do a
on set something remember lines if I got
the audition so what's he like
like I wanna [ __ ] but I don't have it in
me no I don't have it I literally don't
have it in dog there was a girl that I
was with that she uh she really it was
because the way she equated affection
was through sex and so any other type of
affection whether you called it
beautiful you [ __ ] get hugs kisses
whatever it didn't matter she needed to
[ __ ] to feel important but she didn't
understand at the time I was a
struggling stand-up comic I was working
like two or three jobs I was a full-time
[ __ ] student I just got home it's
12:00 it's a wrap
I'm not trying to [ __ ] something's wrong
with Gmail right it's just
I'm [ __ ] example give you a
lackluster performance yeah it's gonna
be the bottom of the barrel Netflix
movie to shoot CSI you should know like
if we see if you're on top it's like
okay well let's I'll just be on top it
don't matter if I'm tired I'm a grower
not a shower yeah yeah you gonna feel
that [ __ ] turn into a peanut in a sec oh
yeah this is gonna be just soaking in
you just gonna bend my dick in half yeah
it's just gonna fall out of here like
she like where to go I don't know I'm
tired
get off of me guys sometimes like have
you ever like [ __ ] somebody and then
like I don't know what it is but maybe
you like [ __ ] too much that to the point
where they want to go for a second round
like you dig just starts to get soft
it's like yeah falls out yeah you gotta
have magic control over you oh you guys
I hate bro bro she starts to [ __ ]
play with it like one of them old
Nintendo joysticks you like yo stop stop
she starts blowing at it like a
cartridge it's not a Nintendo big Latos
that's not gonna work [ __ ] blowing
spit all over my hand like PCs go you
might tap it make sure it works like
[ __ ] she put them to her ear hello ru
stop one [ __ ] Twitter video of that
girl who was grabbing a dick like it was
a it was a stick shift oh yeah yo y'all
gotta be careful with these things
it's like I get it it goes around and
does but that [ __ ] hurts like stop about
this I don't think those realize like
how sensitive a dick is no no is it
sensitive is [ __ ] there's a flick it
like that up it's gonna it's it's
bruised it's a wrap it's Bruce it's a
it's a how long have you been living
together since February okay
was it hard to get adjusted when you
first moved there you know what it was
it actually fixed our relationship a lot
because uh you know text just to go back
to text text me you can misinterpret of
everything to attack so like for me if I
text somebody cuz you know it depends
like it's it's what I'm doing right so
she was she likes like emojis and all of
a sudden [ __ ] sometimes I want to text
that stuff and it would seem like either
I was angry or I was upset and then we
not to interpret how we feel through
words when you don't get to hear it so
now that if I'm in front of her she says
something I just look at her face oh
she's in a good mood room is it's just
some other [ __ ] yeah so it fix a lot of
things but at the same time like we did
it we did definitely have to figure out
what we had to do when our relationship
yeah
because being with somebody like oh this
is some funny [ __ ] I saw I'll show you a
photo later because of how funny it was
I was so pissed at her a couple days ago
yeah we were get into an argument I told
like I'm very unhappy with you like I'm
not happy and the reason why was because
I've been working so much that the few
moments that we do have together it has
to be good like we can't bicker or
ignite because that's gonna piss me off
yeah it's like I you this is the only
time we get to interact with each other
and you're giving me [ __ ] or I'm giving
you [ __ ] I don't want this yeah and so I
was so [ __ ] mad at her and she went
to go to sleep first
right and I remember I walk in the door
I open the door and I said I [ __ ]
hate that face and so I closed that
[ __ ] door and I slept in this podcast
Doug I took these two mattresses here I
laid it on the floor I put my feet up on
that yellow couch sleep that way cuz I
didn't want to wake up and see her face
in the morning but sometimes it's okay
to be there angry yeah be there and we
get it cuz if you hold that in instead
that's even worse and then I got even
more angry because I was like hold on
why does she get the bed I had the were
sleep of my life she woke up refreshed
right ready to go yeah she's ready to
talk to you slept in the worst condition
ever it was been Wawrzyniak
just like man that was such a good sleep
just snoring away I'm over here trying
to figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
with my life
oh my but but that's a different type of
love like you when you're in love and
when you do it like you gonna be mad
like it's inevitable like you're going
to be pissed off some days but then you
know you get over but let me be mad let
me be mad man I see this stand-up
setback of the day
which I'm not sure how well it'll go
over now but i'ma say it anyways I was
like yeah that's what comedy is about
like I remember back in the day on 20/20
I would watch this [ __ ] as a kid there
where it would be videos of like
domestic violence yeah and then you will
look at this man and then he would just
sit there said like I don't know what
came over don't know what came over me
and then I would sit as a kid and look
at that and say you are such a trash how
dare you put your hand on a woman here
and then I met my fiancee and I was like
I get it I understand
no but this brings up a good point like
I get why you would swing at him is this
reason a good point we get so mad
because we can't hit you yeah but you
could hit us but you can and then also
like if me and you get in a that heat of
a debate me you can fight it out oh yeah
well squash it we squat we could fight
it out and we're done we go get food
afterwards yeah it's fine yeah we can't
do that with the horse I can't I can't
like and then we don't know how to
really use our emotions so we're just
like all this bottled up in here because
for a fact I've always said this is like
if you said that [ __ ] to me and you were
a guy I'm we going oh we going at it
yeah we would weed this [ __ ] would be in
wrong you know what I mean but I'm just
sitting there it's like I'm telling you
I would now I'll watch those 20/20
things I'm like I wonder what she said
I'll tell you this though when Chris
Brown's [ __ ] happen the first thing I
said was what she said well we don't
know Chris of course are we not we might
we don't condone out here just hitting
people but I understand the notion of
being angry and you don't know where to
put it like yeah it smelt like as men we
don't and where do we talk growing up
you know fight it out like tougher that
be a man that about so we get old as all
people know we're like
what do I do with this yeah you want to
talk to you yeah you're like like I [ __ ]
you not like you're the [ __ ] like
women are the last boss in a game but
the boss has to cheat code the life bar
just doesn't go down yeah it doesn't go
down look what it is so then so just let
me walk off let me be a yeah just let me
be our I would never ever hit a woman
ever but I definitely would have
thoughts about it like I would you're
human
yes like I'm like I'm telling you there
are some times where I looked at marry
her I'm like could you just look over
the balcony so I could just roundhouse
kick you off this building and see what
happens a joke where you said a girl
he was like nobody gives a [ __ ] about
men to get me to who'd he's like a girl
flick the head of my dick it just walked
off he's like I'm not even mad at the
fact she flicked the head of my dick
I'm at it how confidently she left like
it was nothing she said I've never
wanted to punch a [ __ ] in the back you
know it's like a digging ingo like some
rude [ __ ] dude I know some people who
are in relationships right now and they
would tell me about the [ __ ] that
they're like a significant other says to
him like the girl will say to the guy
and the guys just like yeah I just had
to sit there and take it when I cut D
dude
they cut deep dude Muriel is so [ __ ]
funny because back in the day mind if
she knows like 4 languages so I think
sometimes like with her she doesn't
understand how certain things translate
so for example before she met me she
didn't realize that there are levels to
cursing like ass [ __ ] damn [ __ ] [ __ ]
all have different levels in the ladder
of what is more offensive right so I
remember I should have called her a
jackass I was like like you're a jackass
right she goes well you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then went dead silent I looked
and I was like we don't do that here
like what do you mean I cursed at you
and I was like no no there's levels of
this I think I called my mom a jacket
like it's a light punch it's a light
like yeah it'll be a jacket I was like I
called you a poopoo head and then you
told me that my parents are divorced
yeah that's what you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
like what were you thinking and girls it
rolls off the tongue real good is it so
easy it's like why do we have
like why would you save it I'm telling
you man like I understand it's like I
understand why you would do it
psychology is is is Wow like the psych
holiday is I don't know it's interesting
relationships in general just I'm just
saying don't don't ever hit a woman no
don't everything it was not it's not a
good look man but if you had those
thoughts I'm with you then yeah go go
get a punching bag
Oh TIFF go go at it go get a punching
bag and see what happens man
just go at it tell you what what are you
currently working on me I got that food
show gotcha okay I booked this thing
with Netflix actually recently yeah so
uh we're gonna be filming that in the
first two weeks of November beautiful
and then yeah that's that's really about
it and right now I'm trying to work on
this this series now the food show
that's your soror your own somebody
else's show the food show sin food is me
and Tim's thing and no get guys the one
that it's on me or somebody else okay I
got cast for that yes and then I'm
working on this I'm just trying to do
stuff that I enjoy I remember you told
me a long time ago like you were telling
us right right at the Tesla when you
first got a Tesla
you showed us Tesla and and then right
afterwards I think we were kind of where
I forgot how we talked about it but you
were like it just gets to a point where
you're like I can't live for everybody
else well I can't I have to do what
makes me happy misery I'm going to be
miserable and I'm so glad to see you
doing that like people don't understand
like the hustle of YouTube when it first
was YouTube you - what's [ __ ] nuts
yeah I tell people did like yeah you
guys used I said you got to understand
we were 21 when we started yep we did a
video every Sunday for like four yeah
comedy dog at shiz [ __ ] crazy
I was like do y'all not understand light
that's when we tell people that now even
other comments go that's a [ __ ] lot
of work like that's a lot of [ __ ]
so you get to a point when you burn a
lie you you you like you look out we
always talk about this burning that [ __ ]
is real like this is why yo you to a
point it's like I have to slow down I'm
not even gonna have a life like I'm not
gonna be able to and if I don't slow
down how am I gonna go experience
something to come back and give
any type of kind I have to go live I got
a living that wasn't allowing us to live
so we had to come up with a way like you
know this ain't work how it is and this
that's why I loved your post about the
Tesla and other stuff he's just like no
no none of this [ __ ] just mean that like
I need to be happy like I Drive around
my Honda Element that shit's a four
thousand dollar car just chillin and
people don't understand it either and
they don't understand why I like that
car so much like there's there's a
couple of reasons first off the gas it's
probably amazing oh I'll tell you this
right now people you know it started off
as kind of a joke yeah because actually
do like the Honda Element a lot it's a
[ __ ] boxy a scar but the the thing
that I like about it is a couple of
things it's not to really keep me humble
or mega make a statement or anything but
it's really just to say I'm putting
value into things that I care about now
I don't care about cars I care about
nice cars just to like a roll up on
someone to be like I got in his car
that's dumb
that's [ __ ] stupid I haven't been a
big car personally yeah so is I'm a
point A to point B people are ask me
what kind of car were you I was like of
course I see car like oh that's a nice
car like habit but I'm not like desire
like it's in my dreams and I thought
like I just want to be able to get off I
could get a nicer car for sure I don't
know but for me to I mean next year I
might have to get a nicer car you know
one last legs weird flicks but okay yeah
[ __ ] it whatever like you know what I
mean by nicer cars the car that's worth
more than three times I thought about
something that was built in the recent
years not in the old age yeah but yeah
now it's true are you you you put in
valuing things like all right if I want
to go on a bit instead of buying a car
I'll take my fiance on a vacate like
I'll do something there but I did so
yeah like cuz I underst I thought what
the fact that you travel a lot because I
look at traveling experiences the same
way I did the first time I experienced
it right I could look back on it and be
happy I don't look back on the fact that
I bought a test I'm like oh I bought a
Tesla that feeling is gone that was one
day you did it and I moved on from it
right the car was dope super comfortable
whatever but it's not something that I
kept and and yeah I make enough money
where if I did buy a new car it wouldn't
really affect my financial state many
much right but at the same time I grew
up so poor like money is always money to
me
three hundred dollars a hundred dollars
fifty bucks it's still a lot of it
you're still it's still a lot of money
to me there's a $25 pardon what the [ __ ]
are y'all talking about that's what I'm
saying it's crazy like the only time I
get in trouble with that is with food
but oh yeah other than that man I'm just
like uh you know like do I really need
this and I think about this too like if
I could spend that money on a vehicle or
some nice [ __ ] then I could give that to
my parents I could save it up for when
at home you need some money and I could
give him some cash like those type of
things make me feel really good you know
honestly David I've been meaning to ask
you best rap for you guys someday try
that first that's my first night you
know what I guess I had to see what I
got like if you really were strapped for
cash I would give you cash yes that's
the that's the cool that I know like we
built the relationship over the years
like you're not just gonna meet somebody
but I are I'm gonna give you cash but
it's like I actually feel like we were
talking about you Tim it was like it's
people that we look at we like I can
[ __ ] with you I can hang out with them I
can talk to them I know tango asked me
no stupid [ __ ] we could talk about life
and some people you like I can't do that
yeah like I'm not not doing it I'll be
real - the way that I give money to
people like you should give money
without strings attached that's a lie I
have strings attached my strings
attached is this it's like if I give you
the money yeah you could do whatever you
want with it but it better be for the
[ __ ] that you would said you was for
okay that's gonna piss me off
also - I got a respect to human being
like for example like let's say I don't
know some [ __ ] should happen with
with all your guys or [ __ ] right but I
know that you guys work hard and
everything else and it may not be in the
most lucrative way possible you know
what we do but I would just give you the
money just because I respect what you're
doing because the work is there yeah you
know so she's like well [ __ ] it and you
know we're not gonna [ __ ] it off and go
do exactly well I gave you this money
why are you in the strip pool I seen you
last night oMG laughing what are you
doing it up I left somebody money to pay
off his taxes they didn't forgot - you
know whatever land I give people money I
don't I don't lend it so it's more like
if I haven't if I'm financially stable
enough where I could lend you money I'm
also financially stable enough where I
could give you money
yeah actually so if I don't have the
money I just don't give it out yeah
because it's like why would I do that so
much exactly like I love myself more
that I'm not gonna do
here you go so I lent it I gave him
money there's like a couple grand and
the next day this full on his credit
card bought a flat-screen TV and I will
physically Whoopi we will go to what the
Fonz I'm sure bro on some [ __ ] what type
of human are like like inside how could
you even look at yourself and be like
this is okay and I posted on Instagram
story like I was gonna see that [ __ ] oh
that's some [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] you
oh I call that full immediately like
immediately dude with a J I said it
means you I said they said my black came
out immediately on a Sunday I said I
called them up I said this [ __ ] I said
return that [ __ ] now absolutely well I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up man I was like I gave
you 2 grand that's why and then you put
that [ __ ] on your credit card and this
fool was talking about he's like I know
man I'm just like going through so I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't care what what
you're going I don't care I don't care
what I gave you this for what you're
going through
yeah so go do that well what they don't
make I don't give a [ __ ] if you could
beat my ass see that I'm gonna [ __ ] you
up I'll figure out a way there's
crowbars you know I mean hey listen we
can figure out with this weapon we got a
mic these people figure out karate ways
I will [ __ ] ya that's just disrespectful
[ __ ] man like I can't believe that [ __ ]
man like and I've learned the the whole
money gaming thing from my dad and just
because he goes like if you really care
about somebody you're not gonna ask for
that money back because it makes things
weird it puts pressure yeah because if
they've generally [ __ ] with you they can
get bit they'll pay it back either in
work or either in you need a favor like
what they'll pay it back in that way I
gave somebody money recently
and I asked him to pay me back because I
feel it's weird because what he asked me
for the money they needed I respect the
guy a lot but my thing was like I said
I'm give you this money because I've
actually lent him money like five or six
times oh he gave it to him but only
because he really did and I understand
his art craft doesn't really make a lot
of money for sure and he's still working
[ __ ] hard I believe in the dude so
this last time I was like
I'm gonna give this money I'll say but
if you take it it's gonna come to the
lecture are you ready for this all right
and he took it so I just told my was
like you're actually gonna have to pay
me back on this one because you are in a
financial situation not because you
can't make money it's because you only
want to make money the way you want to
yeah and you'd rather take money from
somebody else then really bite down hard
on your mouthpiece I want you to do it
and you can't do it so you can make
money I was like it's just you only want
to make money the way you want to it was
like when I was doing like YouTube just
you know vlogs and stuff they were cool
but that's not what I wanted to do for a
living I did it because it brought money
and it allowed me to build out things
that I wanted to do like you have to
understand that you're in a very
fortuitous position where you're
choosing not to make money mmm that's a
big difference than not making money
exactly you are choosing not to so
especially if it's been five six times
like alright something there's a there's
an equation here that you got to figure
out yeah and I'm like saying like you're
working on your craft you know you're
working on this [ __ ] and I understand so
I see the hard work so I don't really
feel bad like lending you some money but
now it's at a point where you have to
really earn your own way whether you
like doing it or not you just have to
[ __ ] do it yeah so those are those
type of common we're at an hour and a
half in dog that's just crazy
that's good every time like I had [ __ ]
it like I said when I had my kid
Emmanuel it was like an hour and a half
this usually goes for 45 minutes
really yeah we just like [ __ ] talk no
it's just
Annabelle that's that's that's a
testament to our relationship is like we
think we can talk about it we I can
literally make up a conversation about
anything
dog I'm talking about here's the weird
thing man you know I'm always so [ __ ]
awkward around white people it's like
I'm trying to get rid of that [ __ ] it's
because I grew up in a black beauty
supply store
like a black church growing up I don't
know how to to talk to white people
there and you know like people don't
understand this [ __ ] it's like I don't
understand what the fear comes a black
people are the most [ __ ] inviting
warm people I've ever met in my [ __ ]
life dude hey I'm not here threatening
nobody yeah I met very good dude like
hood do this this [ __ ] blew my mind let
me tell you how I watched the movie
bridesmaids came out that movie is
[ __ ] hilarious mother [ __ ] the my
[ __ ] is funny yeah
I was in a studio deep in Atlanta
Georgia with just where you would like a
trap house uh-huh
got there to do is like hey man what's
up man come on in they had water for us
every day came hey guys take your time
we'll start with you right so we start
with working his homeboy comes in hoodie
DUP bandana DUP da da da him and he was
like oh hey what's up he introduced a
about what's up man he was like nice to
meet you pleasure to meet you I was like
this dude sounds like chick-fil-a you're
talking to us he goes let me tell you
something
bridesmaids that [ __ ] movie is
amazing we all looked at him we said
what we he was like yeah you know that
new movie that just came out bro I just
went seen that and he says I wasn't did
my [ __ ] funny [ __ ] with them like
that [ __ ] was funny and I was like I was
like I don't get this notion of where
this threatening feel of like black
people I was like he came in yeah he
might that this is how he dresses but he
came in he talked to me what he was like
he just went seeing bridesmaids he was
like nothing but white people in a haze
I went by myself it was a great movie
cool dude it's just like media a lot of
its media perception yeah and also too
it's just like my thing is this I'm only
scared of people who are like South Pole
jeans because I know for a fact you wear
the prison you just you're a different
individual cuz why would you even wear a
thong why you got South Pole jeans in
the [ __ ] broke like it's a brand
again yeah like I was a not when I went
back home sack there's like a certain
part of second but it's really good yeah
and you know I think we live in nicer
areas now I'm not used to like hood ass
areas anymore you know me later when I
go back I I'm a judgmental [ __ ]
I'm like you [ __ ] you guys they
get the [ __ ] out my like and the funny
thing is like just like 12 years ago I
was that how was that dude hanging
outside looks like so a lot of it is
perception like that's what it is but
it's just like but like you say it like
she sits on the most inviting war like
you're not just run up the EULA hey give
it life
yeah I think the cool thing about just
like I think like just any kind of like
acne people I just like white Americans
I feel like we all just kind of mind our
own business
we don't be bothering you there's
there's a cup that swine I sit with the
cookout [ __ ] in the bekkie in it these
are people just having a [ __ ] mad in
their business is it [ __ ] isn't it the
only time I [ __ ] get a noise if
somebody's doing a cookout they don't
invite me like yo man I want to play
yeah what is this energy this is Baca oh
yeah so this is this is a buddy of mine
his name is Tommy Lim he's an artist so
he did a collaboration with this piece
yeah this is this is basically four loko
oh no no this is for local oh [ __ ] no I
had this [ __ ] last week when he came on
the podcast I'd do a flight out that day
I was [ __ ] up til the next day you
were wired her I was wired and I wanted
to throw up and I wanted to die the same
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is [ __ ] this is for loco
this is for loco that is wild yeah so he
did the artwork for this [ __ ] he's like
one of my favorite artists that's cool I
mean I can't read it but that's cool you
can get a Food Network yeah they got
like this french [ __ ] on there right
right
do they we have a we have the salmon in
little top tile here I don't know what
the [ __ ] you saying his axe is so thick
but they'll have like this chef named
chef morimoto he's just like oh today we
have a salmon and then we have a black
your eyes like you know what but it's
all subtitle says salmon and rice you
[ __ ] but you've got this French as like
the funniest [ __ ] there's this fan was
shot by our house this Asian woman I go
in there specifically to hear her talk
to me because she's so nice and I think
she knows she's speaking fast and I
can't understand her because all my
answers are you lying
[Laughter]
she what and it's she's so sweet she
tells me stories all the time and I had
to go home and say all right so I think
she told me her daughter went to the
bank and the bank wasn't able to divide
I'm trying to piece us
because she's talking so fast and be so
funny she's actually cursing you I
didn't get the [ __ ] out the place but
you don't even know me I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you I must like your leg off stupid
son of a [ __ ] that's the cool that's
why I [ __ ] with so many of my comedian
but we can joke about racing and we can
hug each other
but that's like it's just life like we
just is it is what it is we're not out
here I'm not saying I hate you and I
never want let it's just funny [ __ ] like
but that's like the cool thing about you
know what it is - is roast culture like
we didn't grow if you didn't grow up
with roast culture you don't understand
and anything is possible yeah in this
conversation like I found out when I
came to this city specifically because I
don't have a lot of black friends out
here I think you guys are the only ones
and then a rose culture is very it's
very particular a lot of people think
they can roast each other but they can't
yeah like I could say some of the most
fucked-up [ __ ] you could say the
fucked-up [ __ ]
and as long as somebody's laughing it's
cool so I found out immediately
immediate I found out immediately that
people just don't roast each other work
that out here so I for example there was
a girl she came at me with like some fat
joke so I'm sorry oh she likes the roast
or some [ __ ] right the [ __ ] had no
titties an ass so I just started going
in on her ass right I was like I
literally told her I was like if we were
lost on the island I will lay you down
flat and let the rain hit your chest so
you could collect water because actually
goes in yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I remember that joke specifically cuz I
had the room dying laughing right and
then she didn't talk to me for a couple
months she didn't [ __ ] with you guys
that's nuts and that's just a regular
job yeah it was it wasn't even that hard
I was like oh that's just some I was
like if you made fat jokes I couldn't I
could say whatever I want about you one
of the best roast jokes I ever heard in
my life
Nayeem that's in the plastic cup boys
kept a hearty and I'm Lynn they had his
old video DVD called Street snaps
uh-huh he told this white girl yeah he
said your teeth are so big if you sneeze
you'll bite a hole in your chest I said
yeah
do you not smart of a joke I said what
oh [ __ ]
she started crying you [ __ ] get out
of here and then he said he said you you
can choose straw to a friend put a fan
he's like this it's like baby shoes oh
he was going it but that [ __ ] if he's
saying it to me I'm wrong I'm laughs it
is funny that is fine
I love this because like one nice life
man be happy though I'm not saying I
don't want to hang out with you there's
just funny Joe but I'll get [ __ ] what
people roast you told me I look like a
Jamaican youth pastor I said [ __ ] you
got me I'm nothing well I love that
roast but I found out too real quick
when some people like I have a friend
right now where she thinks that man I
always have to say have a friend because
I can't say anything
yeah but you know like she thinks that
she could roast so well right but I know
for a fact if I started roasting in the
rap it's a rap like we wouldn't be
friends so I'm just like I'm just like
ah you got me I just have to take it
because there's there's nothing that I
could say to her that she'll just take
lightly because I know I know so much
[ __ ] about it yeah yeah destroy like I
know all your deepest darkest shits
right now I could [ __ ] roast you for
days and then you would question life I
like I like a good roaster where I'm
laying in bed did he do that like all
right like how did he okay cool cool and
so as comedian like people like us like
if you got a good roast on me today and
I have enough I'll be thinking about
this alright next time I see David I got
I'm way for the right opportunity I got
but this is all love like this is down
oh man it makes me laugh but because we
grew up with that yeah it was so fun
because no hard feelings yeah and
there's no hard feelings because I'm
just kind of enjoying the [ __ ] joke
as long as it's really creative it was
good like that
sneezing by the hook now that you that
is amazing some people dude they just
got some people got like heaven gala
lady they just they just they got it
they got it like I remember the first
time I saw Naima Lynn he's like I
honestly think that name Lynn stand-up
was better back and they did it is now
and I think maybe it's because he's
writing for a lot of kevstac he's giving
him like the best but dog when I watched
Kevin Hart live in Sacramento Nayeem was
the funniest one even before even Kevin
Hart said he's funny he was in tears
laughing this bull said he says like you
know sometimes like black voters are so
[ __ ] dumb you
like that's how he started that [ __ ] off
he's like why he's like because this
[ __ ] he was like I have my [ __ ]
on a poster and this dude
thought I was like [ __ ] around he was
like yo man he goes ah I didn't know
your name was Naeem because I thought
your name was now I'm lying
[Music]
stupid I mean he just like clowning on
my but that's the funniest [ __ ] you I
could talk about my culture all day girl
then you can talk like it just does just
that she's fun now I'm lying yeah that's
hilarious
yo he had the whole [ __ ] ass for a
tiem just cracking the [ __ ] yeah like a
20 minute set and I thought his 20
minute set was better than Kevin's hour
that's why I love Andrew shows and all
the people who are just pushing their
humble and they just hand [ __ ] it like
we just our real tail comedy like cuz
like when you look at oh yeah
and you were allowed to like it or
dislike it they just move on and move on
yeah they're not they're not trying to
create a social movement working a
second I'm just working a [ __ ] set
man yeah man yeah but amen with that
raps in this podcast yeah yo where can
they find you
alright uh you can follow me at I roam a
lot I are ome a lot on Instagram and
Twitter roam green jr. it's my snap dorm
Taemin is the group on everything and
shout your podcast oh yes have a podcast
called the comedy Trap House that comes
out on Tuesdays and we have a patreon
where we talk about like spiritual stuff
we talked about energies and healing and
all the LA [ __ ] you could ever think you
know this life [ __ ] I talk about Boss
Hogg that's what it's called on patreon
and you can search that on patreon
comedy Trap House yeah man that's all
the stuff well you can find the genius
brain podcasts on iTunes Spotify all
those audio platforms give us that five
star leave in the comments below about
the [ __ ] dumb stupid [ __ ] we were
talking about pretty much next time
peace peace